Okay the answer to this question is one over
eight, 1 8th probability of having an affected child. So
let's see why this is. Let's take it one step
at a time. Let's go to our affected individuals which
we know must be homozygous recessive based on the
autosomal recessive pattern. If you're affected that means you must
be homozygous. Now let's look at the father's father. He
must pass down one recessive allele. One of the minuses.
But the father here is not affected. So we
know that the other allele must be the dominant.
This means that the father has a probability of
one of being heterozygous. We know the father's heterozygous. Now
let's come over here to the grandmother. Again, she
must have passed down one recessive copy. And we see
that her daughter is unaffected. So she must have
one normal dominant copy. So this means she's definitely heterozygous.
A probability of one. And what's the probability
that she'll pass down the recessive allele, not the
dominant allele, to her daughter? We know the only
possibility is to be heterozygous, because she's unaffected. But
what's the probability of passing. That recessive allele on.
It's one half, right? There's only one half chance
for that to happen. We assume, because this is
a rare disease trait. That anyone mating in from
the outside is unaffected. So we assume plus
plus here. Type 3 Von Willebrand's disease, along
with many other genetic disorders Are pretty rare.
And so unless we have some reason to think
otherwise, whenever you see individuals mating in from
the outside, we assume that they're homozygous normal. So
the probability of this offspring, of this child,
being heterozygous is one half. So now we have
the couple, the man and the woman, the male and the female. And if they're both
heterozygous, then what's the probability that they'll have
an affected offspring. Well, we can set up
the Punnett square if that makes it easier for us. And we see that, out of
four possible options, one out of four is
homozygous dominant, one out of four is homozygous
recessive, and two out of four are heterozygous. So there's a one in four chance
of being affected or homozygous recessive. So now all we do is multiply the
probabilities that each of the intermediate individuals are heterozygous, along
with the probability that the offspring will be affected, so 1 times
1, here. Times one half times 1 4th
is equal to 1 over 8 which is the solution. Have you had trouble with this? That
is alright. Genetic counselors have to be pretty
good at estimating probability and it takes some time
and you may even want to use a calculator
but hopefully you have a new appreciation. For someone
who can read a pedigree efficiently and answer a
question like the probability of having an effected individual
in a family
[BLANK_AUDIO].